this is an urgent message from the
Department of Sanitation we are facing a
crisis brought on by improper disposal
of a virtually inedible Easter candy I'm
talking of course about peeps every year
at Eastern millions of people are left
uneaten these peeps which are not
biodegradable accumulate in landfills
and wash down storm drain resulting in
great harm it'll be loud that's why this
year we're urging people to recycle
their uneaten peeps peeps are made from
a durable and versatile material that
has many uses including leveling tables
scrubbing caked on grease a great
substitute for packing peanuts keep nuts
if you will but protective sporting gear
medical implants as a bpa-free plastic
home installation it's slightly less
toxic than asbestos military training
watch out Isis in our long-term plan
sending peeps to space some man can
eventually set up a colony on planet
peep so think before you throw those
peeps away you can make a difference for
my peeps to yours
you
you